Elizabeth starts off this our Midland
Odessa Texas hi Elizabeth
how are you I'm good how are you better
than I deserve what's up well our
conovan of the day we're about $70,000
in debt and we have two vehicles one of
them is no longer running and I can get
maybe 200 from it for salvaging it the
other we owe about $20,000 on however
what is the other fifty thousand in debt
well I decided to go to private college
when I graduated high school and I think
it's finished cuz I fixed so some of it
cool some of its thickness so that
personal loan fifty thousand dollars in
sickness and student loans medical
building loans yes sir Wow okay in a
twenty thousand dollar car and what's
your household income twelve thousand
now it's sixty sixty-five thousand are
you still ill actually yes I was working
for about two months and I feel sick
again and it's something different this
time and still going through a lot of
testings and doctors here are more
expensive than they were in the last
place we're at so your your husband is
the only one working yes sir and he
makes sixty five thousand yes sir okay
what's he do here's actually well
there's not really a title he's just
helping to build branches at the moment
right now his company is paying for our
rent because I'm moving at different
places every year so it's kind of hard
I'll get a job I'll work there for a few
months either I get ill or we ended up
losing again that's been tough it's been
it's up here yeah sounds like it
okay but you make sixty five thousand
dollars a year how much are you paying
in rent we are not paying any on rent
his company just bought us a camper and
we've been living in the chamber for the
last five months and they've been paying
the rent for us okay because I move you
so often yeah way too much how often do
you move well this is my third place in
the last year okay so every four five
months every four five on each other
okay this is actually the longest we've
been in one place what is your long-term
plan with that she intend to do does he
intend to do this for ten years
hopefully not we're hoping that in about
a year we can get back to our hometown
area which is up there in Amarillo and
they're thinking about building a branch
up there and he's going to want to help
build a branch up there and he's gonna
ask to only get up there if we can stay
there and just run that branch yeah
please I'd be working on that now yeah
they start to talk about it because this
is untenable for you guys to do this for
an extended period of time for only
$65,000 a year how old is he
he's 23 all right that's good now what's
the car worth the car the one we're
running the the $20,000 debt car well it
is worse I want to say I'm 8,000 to
9,000 which really 21% rate on it we
remember those Blue Book it's nine
Galbraith 20,000 isn't right then yeah
well our interest rate on it is 21%
interest rate doesn't affect the payoff
balance it only affects the total of the
payments so you got screwed when you
bought this car on the interest rate and
I'm guessing that they they're not
giving you the payoff balance they're
giving you the account balance because
it's called t.o.p total of payments at a
rip off finance company what you need to
find out is what your actual payoff is
if you walked in today and wrote them a
check and paid it off what's the deal
and I'm gonna guess and say that's about
14,000 okay we asked them what it would
do if we give it back to them
they said it would be called a volunteer
a voluntary repossession and they're
going to sue you for the difference
really stupid don't do that that's what
I thought oh my so we might as well just
keep it until we can pay it off but
we're kind of in that debate because we
have to notice vehicles this one's given
us one of them doesn't run we can get
$200 for it this one that the ACE is
starters messing up their air
conditioners messing up the speedometer
is off which we found out this weekend
we went on road trip and I want to
approach it you learn on a road trip
yeah I had to go home for my birthday
that sounded like a princess you're
broke your cars don't run your $70,000
in debt and you have to go home for your
birthday where yeah okay we're gonna
have to get you we're gonna just roll up
our sleeves here kiddo there's got to be
some stuff straightened out you're gonna
quit managing your life by feelings and
start laying out a game plan and really
start to do some stuff that's smart so
this cars got to be sold and you've got
to get the early payoff of what it is
it's not a $20,000 payoff it should be
around 14 call the finance company and
ask them what it costs to write them a
check today and pay off the car in full
it should be around 14 it should not be
20 don't ask them what the account
balance is ask them what the payoff
today is there's a difference with a
ripoff finance company and how they set
up the books you follow me and then
let's let's lay out a written budget of
every dollar and where it's going and
then let's try to figure out any way we
can do anything we can do to create
income as fast as possible and begin to
clean up these messes of the school
loans and the medical bills and the cars
that won't run and let's get the car
sold get you to $2,000 cars that you pay
cash for and then you move up in car
only after your debt free and that you
can pay cash for a better car and no
more trips and no more crap and no more
eating out and no more goofing around
with money
you're not 14 you're
grown up it's time to pay the bills and
it's time to roll up your sleeves and
get real serious about it I'm not being
mean to you I'm loving you I hope you
hear the love it's in there you have to
listen but it's in there you can do this
stuff but your life is not fun right now
it's not fun it's stress - stress -
stress the stress but you're making your
financial decisions based on your
feelings not based on a game plan and
you got to lay out a game plan and you
got to execute the game plan and you can
do it so hold on I'm gonna have Kelly
send you a copy of a book called the
total money makeover and I want both you
and your young husband to read this
thing and I want you to lay out a game
plan I want you to attack and as you're
fighting it if you get scared or you
don't know what to do you call me back
and I'll help you I'll walk with you
through this but it's time it's time
it's time for you to do this this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you
you